how do we almost get a different face
for Indiana Jones and what happened to
the Creator's bizarre idea to combine
Magnum PI with Quantum Leap we're
tracking down all the clues behind
Magnum Pi's surprising history Hollywood
is full of instances of near misses when
it comes to iconic roles Tom Selleck
discovered that he had been chosen to
Frontline a new movie by Steven
Spielberg called Raiders of the Lost Ark
in the role of an adventurous
archaeologist named Indiana Jones
unfortunately the role came just as
selik was starting work on Magnum PI
after years of failed Pilots Selleck
made the decision to stick with Magnum
PI instead of going for Raiders of the
Lost Ark Harrison Ford was finalized for
the role of Indy Jones instead and the
rest is Cinematic history
one of the most iconic parts of Thomas
magnum's mythology was the red Ferrari
he drove while chasing down suspects and
or beautiful women just one problem at
six feet four inches tall select was too
big to fit into a normal Ferrari to get
around this problem magnum's Ferrari had
its padding removed so he would be
placed lower on the seats the seats were
also bolted as far away from the
steering wheel as possible to
accommodate selik's long legs thanks to
the popularity of the show red Ferraris
became a hot commodity on the buyer's
market in the 80s and 90s the MCU has
popularized the concept of a shared
Cinematic Universe around the world but
the concept of different movies and
shows existing in the same universe and
occasionally crossing over is not a new
one television shows in particular are
often willing to have crossover episodes
between different properties belonging
to the same Studio besides using many of
the same sets as the classic series
Hawaii 5-0 Magnum PI had a couple more
direct crossovers the season 7 episode
novel connection featured Angela
Lansbury's character for Murder She
Wrote while the characters from Simon
and Simon appeared in a season 3 episode
of Magnum PI possibly the most bizarre
crossover though was one that did not
actually end up happening there was a
time when Magnum PI was primed to cross
over with the acclaimed Sci-Fi Action
show Quantum Leap both shows being
created by TV Legend Donald Bellisario
the premise of Quantum Leap was that its
lead character can lead into the bodies
of different people using sci-fi Tech
and become those people for as long as
needed to solve a case in the early
1990s Magnum PI had already ended Tom
Selleck had moved on to other roles
Quantum Leap was struggling to get
picked up for a fifth season but lasario
conceived of a way to keep the show
going by replacing Selleck with Scott
Bakula in a fresh series of Magnum PI
Adventures specifically bellisario's
idea was to have bacula's lead character
from Quantum Leap Thomas Beckett leap
into the body of Thomas Magnum thus
Beckett would become the new Magnum and
keep Quantum Leap running for a few more
years the idea did not go much further
than some test footage being shot of
bacula wearing magnum's iconic Hawaiian
shirt instead the fifth and final season
of Quantum Leap had Beckett leaping into
the body of Lee Harvey Oswald despite
being a crime drama show Magnum PI also
featured plenty of comedic moments most
such scenes took place between Thomas
Magnum and the snooty British caretaker
of the house he lived in Higgins Higgins
was one of the few characters who could
be reliably counted upon to cut the
Brash Magnum down to size eyes with his
dry wit time and again the vast
differences between the fastidious
Higgins and the rambunctious Magnum was
comedy gold you're wonderful
woman
well I wouldn't say that but maybe the
funniest part is that actor John
hillerman who played Higgins wasn't
British at all he revealed that fans
would write to him assuming he was
British and he would reply I hate to
disappoint you but I'm a hick from Texas
hillerman's British accent which he had
honed as a stage performer was so good
that even British fans believed him to
be the real deal Selleck told thr I
would go around London in a cab and
they'd ask where's the Brit John
hillerman from on your show and I'd tell
them he was from Denison Texas
despite solving so many Mysteries across
his show the one Mystery Thomas Magnum
could never solve was the identity of
his mysterious benefactor Robin Masters
whom he never meets face to face this
led to a lively debate among fans as to
the identity of Robin Masters many fans
and Magnum himself believed Higgins had
been Masters all along but the voice of
Robin Masters as heard on the show does
not resemble Higgins voice in fact the
voice of Masters was provided by Cinema
Legend Orson Welles with Belisario
revealing in an interview Robin Masters
was never Higgins
one of the most iconic parts of the
mythology of Magnum PI was the special
ring that Thomas Magnum and his allies
TC and Rick wore the ring was a Memento
from their time spent together during
the Vietnam war the two crosses at the
center of the Ring are a reference to
the cross of Lorraine which is
associated with Joan of Arc and which
was once used by the Knights Templar
like the true identity of Robin Masters
though just what the ring signifies to
Magnum and his friends remains a mystery
Magnum PI never tried to hide the fact
that it's charismatic and heroic lead
was a Vietnam War veteran and there's a
good reason for this Tom Selleck served
in the military before becoming an actor
and he strongly disagreed with a
negative portrayal of veterans in pop
culture at the time Donald Bellisario
the creator of Magnum PI had also
previously served in the U.S Marine
Corps together select and Belisario were
determined to make Thomas Magnum into an
example of a Vietnam War veteran
character who is actually heroic instead
of Simply being damaged goods Selleck
told AARP I don't want to get too
emotional but I am very proud of this
Magnum was recognized as the first show
to portray Vietnam veterans in a
positive way when Magnum PI was first
being developed the plan was for the
main character to be just like James
Bond a Suave hard drinking and
womanizing Man of Action that men would
want to be like but this
characterization did not sit well with
selling even though he was perfectly
aware he could easily carry such a role
based on his natural Charisma Belisario
later revealed in an interview that
Selleck told him I just don't want to
play with I look like I really want to
do something with humor with that in
mind Thomas Magnum became a much more
laid-back character fighting crime in
shorts and a Hawaiian shirt instead of a
tuxedo Selleck's instincts proved
correct and his take on Thomas Magnum
became an iconic figure in pop culture
in its own right instead of being seen
as a James Bond knockoff by the time of
the show's seventh season Magnum PI was
running out of steam thus the decision
was made to end the show after its
seventh season with the season finale
limbo serving as the end for the entire
series the episode sees Magnum caught in
a shootout inside a warehouse he gets
mortally wounded and winds up in the
hospital fighting for his life after
going into a coma Magnum becomes
conscious as a ghost-like figure he
spends the rest of the episode trying to
keep his client safe from a group of
killers and also saying goodbye to his
old friends and allies before moving on
to the afterlife although the episode
appears to end with Magnum entering
Heaven parts of the story were later
re-edited to make magnum's end less
definitive after it transpired that the
show had been picked up for one more
season season 8 thus begins with Magnum
waking up from his coma after his
near-death experience and getting back
to work in the late 1980s Tom Selleck
did something shocking he decided to
walk away from Magnum PI while it was
still bringing in solid ratings why
Selleck later told CBS that he wasn't
sick of the character he was just worn
out from the unrelenting work schedule I
was tired from Magnum because I was
doing 90 hour weeks for eight years I
wasn't tired of it so it was time what a
nice way to go off what a nice way to
pay homage to the show it was still so
popular I basically have Sundays off and
I wake up maybe about 11 because I'm
exhausted and I eat have some coffee and
and all of a sudden the day's almost
gone a big turning point was his smash
1987 hit film Three Men and a Baby which
brought selik new opportunities in film
opportunities he wanted to explore he
told CBS Magnum never was canceled God
knows how many episodes we could have
done with the number one show on the air
still Selleck may be looking back
slightly with rose-colored glasses in
fact Magnum PI had slipped noticeably in
the ratings by the end with the final
season finishing in 40th Place for the
1987-1988 TV year I really loved the
show and loved doing the character I
never got tired of it but I did get
tired from it Magnum PI is today seen as
a television classic but even when it
was on the air Magnum PI frequently
brought in big viewing numbers and had a
host of distinguished fans one such fan
was Tom Clancy author of such Classics
as The Hunt for Red October and the rest
of the Jack Ryan series despite being
mainly known for writing about serious
men and women in uniform saving the day
it seems Clancy also had a soft spot for
Thomas Magnums more laid back and Breezy
approach to fighting evil Tom Selleck
revealed that Clancy had expressed his
love for Magnum PI to the actor and even
wanted to make a full-length movie about
the character with Selleck in the lead
selik told Yahoo that it almost became a
reality in the 90s Tom Clancy is a huge
Magnum fan we got together and I went to
Universal and I said it's time we could
do a series of feature films they were
very interested and I had Tom who wanted
to do the story unfortunately the
Studio's leadership was in a state of
flux in the 90s and the Magnum PI movie
plans got lost in the constant
reshuffling going on at the time as late
as 2009 Celica was still willing to come
back as Thomas Magnum for a movie that
was in development at the time but so
far nothing has yet come of it if there
is one thing the television industry
hates it's saying goodbye to a hit show
and television audiences never really
said goodbye to Magnum PI after it ended
zelik's show continued to find new
audiences and fandoms during reruns so
naturally CBS tried to cash in on the
popularity of Magnum PI by rebooting the
show for modern audiences the new Magnum
PI debuted in 2018 starring Jay
Hernandez in the role of the new Thomas
Magnum while the show has seen moderate
success moving to NBC in 2023 fans have
often wondered what Selleck thinks about
the new Magnum and whether he would ever
appear in the reboot the answer is no
select told TV Insider they asked and I
said absolutely not Selleck said the
main reason is that his current hit show
Blue Bloods takes up all his time and
attention but he also admitted that the
reality of the new show just couldn't
live up to his expectations or his own
ideas for what a modern Thomas Magnum
should be like he told TV Insider it
will never be what in my fantasy world I
would make it to be would you like to be
the actor to play you play Magnum I
should say oh me